so we've heard from many in the film we
also saw that it's physically difficult
at points to walk the camino emotionally
how was it difficult
i think it's different for each person
um
and that's what makes the camino i think
so magical is it's not this one blanket
experience
and what may be difficult for one person
is easy for another
um and i'm going back on a physical
level for me for example the physical
walking wasn't that challenging but the
staying the snoring was a really
challenging part for me
and emotionally
i had a really interesting experience
when i walked my brother passed when i
was 10
and
i'd done lots of workshops and work
around my brother's death
and then when i was walking the camino
it was almost like he had died the year
before and it and also
on kind of the positive end
i really felt him
i mean it was like he was there with me
and so
i think i kind of
went through a lot more grief and i felt
for me at least
on the camino the goods were so great
and
the pain was so deep like it was
everything is sort of magnified and
amplified
and so
it ends up being
emotionally difficult i think for each
person in their own way
some people have huge problems with the
meseta which is this flat long section
where there's nothing to look at and
it's just fields
um
and i personally really love that
section so
it's it's just so unique for everybody
so then again you said that the real
magic of the camino the real changing of
it happens when you come home and why do
you think that is and how was it for you
well i think
i think it's it's different for
everybody that but i think the kamino
sort of seeps into your life
and
continues to affect you
over time
and for me it was really this calling to
do to make this film
and it's been extremely challenging and
simultaneously
i really feel like
there's a part of me that feels like the
reason i'm on this planet and the reason
i was born was to make this film like
this was part of my destiny or
i'm not even sure what the words are but
i know
i'm doing what i'm supposed to be doing
like this is what i'm supposed to be
doing
and that's a very fulfilling thing
to be
you know feeling like okay i'm doing
what i'm here to do